yeah folks we've been doing some
research on retirement and everybody's
always talking about the rate of return
is important when you retire right of
return rate of return how much are you
making on your mutual fund how much
you're making on your your bank IRA how
much do you make what is your interest
rate what's your rate of return what's
your rate of return what's your rate of
return and you know it matters a lot
whether you get ten or ten and a half or
it matters a lot whether you get 11 or
whether you do a inflation adjusted or
inflation and expense adjusted
calculations and all this you know all
these nerds in my business world and my
lot in my space in the financial space
and meats be included when I was a young
guy we spent an inordinate amount of
time money and brainpower wearing our
little nerd calculators out over a tenth
of a point here or there and you know
what we're actually finding now in the
current research the best research
that's being done in the retirement
space right now you know what the number
one factor about whether you retire with
dignity and have enough money to retire
is it is not the rate of return it is
not whether it's tax-free or tax
deferred it is not whether it's a 401k
or a Roth 401k it's not whether it's a
traditional IRA or Roth IRA it's not
whether you do use a 457 or whether you
use an annuity it's not the type of
product it's not the return it's not the
tax position of it none of that is the
main indicator of whether you retire
with money in your account to retire on
you know what the main indicator is you
have to put money in the account
that's the biggest problem all of this
big media TV media need to be about the
interest rates and all this crap about
these financial products and all these
supposed financial experts with their
freaking theories nobody puts money in
their account failure to contribute is
the number one reason people don't have
any freaking money in their retirement
account it's not that they did it wrong
it's that they didn't do it at all
because the financial world has looked
at them and told them they're doing it
wrong and they're so scared and they're
all god I'm going to mess this up and
I'm afraid my whole life agent and
my mutual fund broker and my broker and
I read money magazine and I listen to
some [ __ ] on Good Morning America and I
watch this and I watch Fox Business and
everybody's got a dadgum opinion and I
don't know what I'm going to do so you
know what I'm going to do nothing that's
the problem you don't put any money in
your account you don't have any money
that's what the research is showing
number one reason it's not ready return
it's not product it's not lack of advice
it's not lack of knowledge it's not
financial illiteracy it's none of that
people don't have money in their
retirement accounts because they didn't
put any money in the account that's the
problem that's why I love Alex's
question cuz that guy right there he's
putting money in his account and he's
doing the calculations and trying to
think about it like a grown up person
who's got control of his own destiny I
love that guy he's a rock star way to go
Alex you made my day man but listen
America quit listen this bunch of
goobers and money might CNNMoney reading
Yahoo Finance about the some
technicality of ain't Agreement selling
too bad gave Ramsey 12% shut up
put money in the account and you will
have money it's magical
this is the Dave Ramsey chef